[Music]
Eugene you've asked one of my favorite
questions and a surprisingly deep one
the essence of it is how fast are we
really moving we are a solar system we
are planets going around the Sun but the
Sun has its own motion around the galaxy
the Milky Way and there are larger
motions still because the Milky Way
galaxy is also moving through space so
I'm gonna try to break this down because
there are a number of different ways to
think about motion because when you get
to these scales one of the most
important questions you have to ask is
motion compared to what and I'll explain
that as I go along
so one of the most easy to understand
motions but a kind of a mind-blowing one
is that the Sun is orbiting around the
center of the Milky Way galaxy
now the Milky Way galaxy is a huge
collection of about half a trillion
stars and it's about a hundred thousand
light years across end to end now we
actually orbit around the center of the
galaxy the sum of the galaxy is about
30,000 light years away from us and we
orbit around about once every 230
million years ok that sounds like a long
time so 230 million years to make one
orbit around the galaxy so how fast are
we going it turns out that the Sun and
us with it are going at about 560
thousand miles an hour that's over half
a million miles an hour just around the
centre of our galaxy so right now you
are moving at over half a million miles
an hour around the center of the galaxy
and if you want to think about it in
kind of a dramatic way you know the
center of the galaxy has a massive black
hole at the middle about 4 million times
the mass of the Sun so right now you are
orbiting a massive black hole at half a
million miles an hour
that's kind of fun but there are larger
velocities as well and here's where
things start to get a little bit
complicated because the universe is
expanding and what that really means
that space itself is expanding it's not
really correct to say the galaxies are
flying through the universe with the
expansion of the universe that's
actually not how it works at all the
galaxies in that sense are standing
still but the space in between them is
getting bigger
it's a very strange thing to think about
but the expansion of the universe is not
galaxies moving through empty space and
one of the reasons that this is
important is because the farther away
you look into space the more expanding
space you look through and it's not that
galaxy is very far away or actually
moving through space very very fast but
they appear that way to us there's
something called the Hubble constant and
what that means is how fast the universe
is expanding for every amount of space
that you look through the Hubble
constant right now is about 75
kilometers per second per megaparsec and
the mega parsec is about three million
light-years so that means that every
three million light years you go out
things are receding from you at an
additional 75 kilometres per second so
when you're three million light years
away a galaxy would naturally recede
away from you at 75 kilometres per
second now double that say that you're
now in six million light years away
double 75 150 kilometers per second so
for every three million light years you
go out you put an additional 75
kilometres per second on to the speed
now that means that galaxies near to us
are not moving very quickly at all in
the natural expansion of the universe
but if you look at something billions of
light years away you're looking through
that much expanding space and it can be
receding away from us appearing to
recede away from us at a very fast
velocity indeed in fact when you
actually look at the very very edges of
the universe things are receding away
from us close to the speed of light so
that's not anything moving at the speed
of light that's just the fact that
you're looking through that much
expanding space then it appears to be
going that fast away from you and this
is called the Hubble law it took a long
time for people to realize that there
might be other motions besides just this
expansion of the universe and we have to
tease them out because things you know
galaxies as big as they are as fast as
they're moving the distances they're
moving across are so vast it's very
difficult to detect over time we
realized that yes indeed there were
other motions besides this what we call
Hubble flow this expansion of the
universe so we began to realize that the
Milky Way galaxy was part of LA
your clusters of galaxies and in some
case those clusters of galaxies were
bound together by gravity sort of
orbiting around big groups of galaxies
and in other cases these concentrations
of galaxies are probably going to
disperse over time as the universe
expands so starting from relatively
close to us the closest large galaxy to
us is Andromeda and Andromeda is so big
and so close that in fact we are falling
towards each other faster than the
universe is expanding us away right now
the Andromeda galaxy is coming at us at
a speed of about 300,000 miles an hour
and that means that it's gonna collide
with us in a couple billion years so I
wouldn't worry about that that's not a
problem for us at all and in fact we
think the Milky Way is collided with
other galaxies in the past as well but
the reason I'm drama is coming toward us
is the force of gravity is accelerating
us together faster than the expansion is
taking it away other galaxies is even
closer to us are orbiting the Milky Way
like the Magellanic Clouds so now let's
go out a little bit further and think
about how the Milky Way is moving
through space compared to larger things
well the largest motion we know of right
now is that we are falling in towards
something called the Great Attractor
and this is a concentration of mass a
giant cluster of galaxies and right now
we're moving at a little over than one
and a half million miles an hour towards
that part of the sky for a long time we
really didn't know what was there we
called it the Great Attractor because it
seemed kind of mysterious but now we
realize that it's actually the center of
gravity of a huge cluster of galaxies
something called a super cluster and
this cluster probably contains over one
hundred thousand galaxies and it's
probably on the order of about half a
billion light-years across and this has
been discovered only in the last few
years it's been called the Laniakea
super cluster Laniakea is the hawaiian
language word for the highest heaven and
this is the largest group of galaxies
that we think that we are actually
gravitationally associated with we are
actually falling in towards the center
of this giant collection of galaxies so
where is the Sun going how are we moving
it depends on with respect to what
we're moving around the galaxy at half a
million miles an hour we're falling into
the center of a super cluster of
galaxies at one and a half million miles
an hour and all of that is superimposed
on top of the expansion of the universe
which isn't really a speed it's just
that you have to look through a lot of
expanding space so there's no one answer
as to how fast you're moving right now
and I think that's one of the most
wonderful things is how complex these
simple answers can get
[Music]